en este vídeo vamos a ver con mayor
detalle la multiplicación de números
cada vez más grandes en particular el
multiplicar números de dos dígitos por
números de un dígito los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
traten de encontrar a que es igual 37
por 6 con algún tipo de método vamos a
tratar de encontrar un método nosotros
mismos una forma de pensar en esto es
por las diferentes posiciones el 3 está
en la posición de las decenas por lo que
son 3 decenas y el 7 está en la posición
de las unidades son 7 unidades así que
podemos descomponer el 37 en tres
decenas más lo pondré en amarillo siete
unidades y vamos a multiplicar esto por
seis otra forma de pensar en esto es que
es lo mismo que podemos reescribir esto
como tres decenas es lo mismo que 37
unidades
es lo mismo que 7 y todo por 6 y podemos
verlo como pueden aplicar la propiedad
distributiva pero solo
quiero que piensen en él porque es
intuitivo tenemos 37 66 y es lo mismo
que 36 es más 76 es ponemos paréntesis
para que todo quede más claro nuevamente
37 de algo es lo mismo que 30 de ese
algo más 7 de ese algo 37 por 6 es 30
por 6 más 7 por 6 y podemos calcular
esto 30 por 6 es 3 por 6 es 18 por lo
que tres decenas por seis es 18 decenas
que es lo mismo que 187 por 6 es 42
ahora sólo debemos sumar estos dos
números y podemos pensar en esto en
términos de las diferentes posiciones
esto está en la posición de las unidades
0 unidades más dos unidades son dos
unidades y ahora pensemos en la posición
de las decenas hay cuatro decenas y ocho
decenas lo que da 12 decenas que podemos
escribir como 120 y aquí queda una
centena
de este lado no hay centenas ponemos 100
sumemos esto 100 más 120 da dos centenas
por lo que es 220 y al sumar dos
unidades quedan 222 todo esto es igual a
222 esta no es la única manera de
resolverlo de hecho podemos hacerlo de
una forma similar pero escribiendo las
cosas de manera que sea más fácil de
rastrear 37 por 6 en esta columna coloco
las unidades y en esta otra columna es
donde escribiré las decenas y si hubiera
centenas las escribiría en esta otra
columna esto es simplemente para seguir
la pista a las cosas y aquí hacemos lo
mismo
tomamos el 6 y podemos decir que es lo
mismo que tres decenas por seis más
siete unidades por seis y podemos
hacerlo en cualquier orden hagamos
primero las unidades si multiplicamos
siete unidades por seis va a ser igual a
42 cuatro decenas y dos unidades como
encontramos esto
con siete unidades por seis o siete seis
es así obtuvimos esto y ahora
multiplicamos las tres decenas por el 6
lo pondremos por aquí 3 decenas por 6
son 36 es que sabemos son 181 en la
posición de las centenas 8 decenas y 0
unidades y de esta manera es más
sencillo sumarlo todo igual que como
hicimos este paso de este lado pero
ahora todo está en su valor posicional
lo que hace más fácil sumar lo dos
unidades más 0 unidades da 2 unidades
4 decenas más 8 decenas son 12 decenas o
una centena y dos decenas por lo que
pongo las dos decenas aquí y pongo la
centena aquí arriba una centena más una
centena son dos centenas aquí lo tenemos
222 el objetivo de esto es apreciar lo
que sucede descompusimos el 37
este número de dos dígitos en sus
valores posicionales tres decenas y
siete unidades
multiplicamos cada uno por 6 en esta
situación lo hicimos de ambas formas
porque son maneras diferentes de
escribir el mismo método